that speech that everybody talks about
inch by inch play by play till we're
finished all football players notice
because they play Any Given Sunday
before a lot of these games he was
having a tough time because this wasn't
his Forte right right so when he was
doing the speech he was doing it like a
speech one inch at a time I went up to
my Mr Pacino can I speak to you humbly
he said yeah I said when you talking to
them you're not their coach you they
fired but a lot of these guys out here
came from broken homes came from the
hood didn't have no father in the
household our coach and anybody could
tell you Byron Scott anybody could tell
you that our coach was basically Our
Father Figure
when I fingernails because they were
with us more than our parents I said so
when you make that speech this time talk
to him like you they daddy Oliver Stone
said in action he says every inch
because we know when we add up all those
inches that's gonna make the [ __ ]
difference between winning and losing